STEPHAN LINZNER: Hello,
everybody.
Welcome to this week's
Android Office Hours
live here from London.
Today is the first birthday of
Google Play, for those who
don't know, so I think
it's a good day to
have an Android Hangout.
So this is Stephan Linzner.
MATT GAUNT: I'm Matt Gaunt.
And in the Hangout down here,
we have Rich and Nick.
RICH HYNDMAN: Hey there.
Yeah, we're not in the London
office today because we've
just got back from a trip to
Israel, where we were at the
campus in Tel Aviv.
I'm sporting the new Campus Tel
Aviv hoodie, whether you
can read it from there.
So Yossi there, in the bottom
corner there, we actually sat
with him about 10 hours
ago, but we just
got back to the UK.
And there was a lot of good
talks on multiscreen
applications and multiscreen
development over at
the campus in Israel.
What were you talking
about, Nick?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, I went and I
gave a talk on how to design
responsive applications
on Android.
So hopefully, people enjoyed
that, and I'll be posting my
slides online soon, so
watch out for that.
RICH HYNDMAN: Absolutely.
I'll be posting mine as well.
MATT GAUNT: Sweet.
STEPHAN LINZNER: Fun.
MATT GAUNT: So as usual,
no more disclaimer.
We are not announcing new
features or product timelines
or anything like that.
It's purely to answer questions
and help out
wherever we can.
So we've pretty much got
a full house already.
So has anyone got any questions
in the Hangout?
No.
STEPHAN LINZNER: No questions
from the Hangout?
OK.
MATT GAUNT: Do you
want to kick off
with a Moderator question?
STEPHAN LINZNER: Yes.
OK, we have a question down here
on using the Crop Intent
or using a customized one.
Yeah, I think it's a difficult
question because if you have
used a Crop Intent before, you
might have noticed that it
will not work on all devices.
And I don't know actually how
official it is, but if you
want to use it, you should
make sure that you have a
fallback option to what
you're doing.
So you could use the Crop
Intent, but you still have to
have a fallback solution
if this is not working.
NICK BUTCHER: I'd have stronger
guidelines than that
and say it's actually not
a documented intent.
So it's well known, but it's not
actually guaranteed to be
there by the platform.
So while you could try and use
it, like you're saying, it's
not guaranteed to be there.
A better approach might be to
copy the functionality from
the gallery application
and do it yourself.
STEPHAN LINZNER: Or do
it on a server side.
Even that might be a
good idea to do.
NICK BUTCHER: Well, you probably
want to be able to
resize it on the client side and
then choose the cropping
area, and then performing the
actual crop is trivial, right?
STEPHAN LINZNER: Right.
NICK BUTCHER: I mean, all
the code is there in the
[INAUDIBLE] app, it's all open
source, but [INAUDIBLE]
if the OEMs modified their
version of the gallery
[INAUDIBLE].
MATT GAUNT: Which is exactly
what's happened with a
question like this saying, that
one particular device
just doesn't work.
It comes back with
something weird.
I mean, you've also got to think
if you can get away with
not involving the user
at all, that's also
another viable option.
I've had applications where we
needed to crop an image just
to make it square, and nine
times out of 10, you didn't
really need to get the
user involved.
So think of a different way
of doing it, I think,
is the way to go.
Should I just jump in right
with the difficult one?
I'm going to do it.
So we had a question.
Can Android destroy stopped
activities of an app if it's
still in the foreground?
The docs suggest it can, but
Hackborn replied it wasn't
necessarily the same case.
Essentially, what Dianne
Hackborn's kind of stated is
that if you have an application
in the foreground
and then you keep on creating
activity after activity,
essentially, you'll get to a
point where you'll run out of
memory and the activities won't
be cleared because the
application is in
the foreground.
So essentially, the best way
to get around this was to
start using fragments.
And essentially that way, you
can start managing memory
itself because you're
essentially able to swap out
the fragments and remove
them, et cetera.
So managing things that way.
I think it's slightly ambiguous
in the documentation
in terms of whether the
activities will be cleared
when they're just in the
background even though the
application's in the
foreground or not.
I think that's where the
confusion has come about.
STEPHAN LINZNER: But you have
to be very careful if you're
running in the foreground and
creating activity over
activity over activity.
I think this is kind of an
architectural problem.
This is also why Dianne said
use a fragments API because
you don't want to create a
new activity every time.
Or what you can do is you can
handle a task that you can use
flags like Single Tap
and refresh the
views, refresh the adapters.
But I think this is how you
should approach [INAUDIBLE].
But this is how you generally
should approach these things.
And to know that if your
application's in the
background, the framework will
be able to kill your activity,
but not if you're running
in the foreground.
MATT GAUNT: And that
was from itai.
And originally, I posted the
comment and he's rightfully
come back saying, given that
it's Dianne Hackborn.
If Dianne Hackborn says
it's true, then--
STEPHAN LINZNER: It
probably is true.
MATT GAUNT: Definitely take
her word over mine.
Next [INAUDIBLE].
When do you think the ability
to reply to comments will be
added to developers?
So again, this kind of falls
neatly under the, we're not
announcing new features,
et cetera.
Google Play have given it
to some developers, but
ultimately, I think the move to
have comments be backed up
by a Google+ profile means that
you could reach out to
users if you wanted to help
them out directly.
But at the moment, there's no
news as to what the Google
Play team are doing
with that feature.
I'm going to jump straight
into the next one.
By the way, if anyone has
another question anywhere,
then feel free.
Stephan, have you got a question
in the Moderator?
Yeah, he has somewhere.
STEPHAN LINZNER: Which one?
RICH HYNDMAN: He's linked
to it as well.
Also, if anyone's got any
favorite apps from the first
birthday celebrations that
they've been downloading, it'd
be good to hear about them.
There's movies, books,
applications, games, all for
sale at the moment in the Play
Store for the first birthday.
The Play is one celebration.
STEPHAN LINZNER: Your question
was the one with the UI
automator, I see.
We still don't have
any news on that.
I saw you open up
a different one.
It should not happen, like I
said last week, but we don't
have an answer for you ready.
I'm sorry.
Should we take on the private
API key question?
MATT GAUNT: Let's do it.
STEPHAN LINZNER: This is also
something that's very
sensitive, I think, because you
should obviously protect
your API keys.
So what should you
do about it?
There's a couple of things
you could do.
In general, if you want to have
a read, there's a blog
post on the Android Developers
Blog on securing passwords,
and maybe use some advice from
there and apply it to secure
your API key.
But in general, you should think
about how sensitive is
it to protect your API
key in general?
Do you have to pay for your API
usage, and how important
is it [INAUDIBLE] or not.
Generally, you should
protect it.
In the Android system, of
course, you should always use
the Flag Private to store
the API key internally.
Of course, on rooted devices,
this won't be accessible, so
if you really have to protect
your API key, you can do some
kind of root detection.
I also posted a link
on [INAUDIBLE]
class where you can do root
detection last week.
This is something you can use to
detect root and only run on
non-rooted devices if this
is something you can do.
And you, obviously, what's
your take on it?
You can do a lot of things.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
I think generally, you've got to
think how hard do you need
to make it for someone to get
the API key, and I think
that's going to be dependent on
the use case, essentially.
I think the way a lot of
companies will get a way
around this will be to do a
combination of server side
support as well as client side,
which the [INAUDIBLE]
kind of covers the client
side of it.
So I think generally, there's
going to be certain methods
that are going to work better
than others, but generally,
it's a case of how difficult
do you need to make it for
someone to then not
be interested in
getting at the API key?
So it will depend
on the scenario.
STEPHAN LINZNER: We'll confer
and investigate on what is the
best practice to do it on
different levels of
[INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: Also, the more
recent API keys now also
require a package name to
be associated with them.
So the Maps API, for example,
your API key can only be used
by you because it takes
your signature and
your package name.
So for our APIs, at least,
we're now securing them
through that mechanism
as well.
Other people's APIs may not use
that, but it is actually
fine to put things like the
Maps API key in plain text
inside your application.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: But other
developers kind of take
advantage of that same
infrastructure, right?
You have the ability to verify
back end calls, so that's
exactly what the Maps
API is doing.
It's a way to verify that the
traffic is only coming from a
certain package.
So if you wanted to, you could
route something through a
server off device, and use the
Google based [INAUDIBLE] token
to verify that it's only coming
from your application,
that isn't some random
web traffic.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, I think if
you search for Cloud Endpoints
on Google+, Cloud Endpoints,
you'll find
it on the API Console.
MATT GAUNT: Nice.
STEPHAN LINZNER:
OK, very nice.
RICH HYNDMAN: While I'm talking
about things on the
API Console, actually, it's
worth mentioning that last
week, a new feature launched
which now allows you, if you
use Google+ sign in on your
website, to have the Install
Now button in your Android
applications.
So users can install your
Android application from your
website directly onto their
device as if they were in the
Play Store.
You don't need to forward them
to the Play Store anymore.
It's part of the Google+ sign
in, as I say, and you get some
great metrics from the Google+
Platform Insights as well.
So have a look at
developers.google.com/+, and
then look for Over
the Air Install.
It's not actually the Install
button, it's part of the sign
in process allows the user to
install your application.
Kind of cool new feature.
MATT GAUNT: Added some more
work for me to do to my
website now.
RICH HYNDMAN: But if you've got
Google+ sign in already,
then you just need to add the
app package name into the
script that's already there and
turn on the API feature in
the API Console.
MATT GAUNT: Cool.
So Nick, we've got a
question for you.
In the last Android Design in
Action, Nick mentioned they
rarely recommend
to use dialogs.
Why is that?
I think it's a useful way not
only to get input data, but
also show a relatively small
amount of info that doesn't
really fit anywhere in
the app, so about
two to three lines.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, my general
hatred of dialogs is just due
to their blocking nature.
It just really disrupts any flow
you might have within an
application.
I just think if you can display
something in lines,
two to three lines could be
given in line somehow, or some
inline use in space element that
you don't have to go to
through an explicit dismissal
or anything like that, and I
find that's better.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah,
I kind of agree.
I think one of the most obvious
use cases for a dialog
is when you're in the middle of
a sign in process, you've
got the username, you've got
the password, and then
something fails and then it
comes up with a dialog saying
something doesn't work.
It's much nicer if you just
show a message above the
actual form, so that way they
can edit whatever they want to
do, or retry there.
By putting up a dialog, you're
almost already flagging up the
fact that something's gone wrong
and blocking them from
trying again.
STEPHAN LINZNER: So you should
only use it in cases where you
need the user's attention and
you need the user input.
But in the other cases, I would
suggest there are other
things in the framework you can
use to notify the user,
tell them what's going on.
But I think dialogs interrupt
user flow, as I wrote on the
Moderator, and this is why you
should be really careful when
using them.
So what else do we have?
AUDIENCE: Can I ask a
question, please?
MATT GAUNT: Go for it.
STEPHAN LINZNER: Of course.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
Is it possible to detect if
the app is open from a
broadcast receiver?
STEPHAN LINZNER: I don't know
if it's possible from a
broadcast receiver, but what
you can do is you can grant
for it to Get Tasks permission,
and you can from
there get the running task.
But you have to be very
careful because you're
requesting the Get
Task permission.
I think there are
one or two ways.
I did that on another project.
But this is one way you can
detect if your application is
still there and also
if it's running.
But I only recommend it in rare
cases, because you're
obviously going to request this
permission, and people
wondering why you're
requesting--
AUDIENCE: What exactly I would
like to know, I would like to
know if the app is open, if the
UI is in the front, and
not just if I can
find the task.
Because you know the app can be
in the task but is not open
at the moment.
It's in the background.
STEPHAN LINZNER: But I think
you can do it with that.
Just type in on Stack Overflow,
there are a couple
of answers on that.
But if I remember correctly,
you can
definitely do it from there.
AUDIENCE: I will
check on that.
Thank you.
STEPHAN LINZNER: What you also
can do, I think one solution
is to register a dynamic
broadcast receiver, and from
then send messages which
you can then receive.
This is something you also
could do because this
broadcast receiver will only
be active if you're running
the program and have
user focus.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
MATT GAUNT: So one of the
questions on the Google+
stream is, do the menu items on
the Action bar support the
checked state?
We tried this but it seems not
to work, from Jens Hohl.
So to the best of my knowledge,
it doesn't support
necessary the checked state,
but what you can do is just
swap out the icon depending
on the state.
So essentially, when you've
created the menu, it's safe to
keep a reference to the actual
menu itself and then at that
point use Find Item by Idea,
I think it is, or something
along those lines, to actually
get a reference to that
particular item, and then
change the icon
depending on the state.
So that's the best way that
I know how to do it.
If anyone else has any
other comments on it?
STEPHAN LINZNER: Yeah,
greetings to Jens.
I know him.
He's a very smart guy.
MATT GAUNT: Another one
from Robert Rees.
Where would you suggest a
new developer to start?
So I think Giovanni has already
responded to the best
place to start, which
is the Android
Developer Training Site.
Loads of tutorials, and just
generally helps you go from
really brand new developers
right through to the really
advanced stuff.
So that's probably a really
safe place to start.
And just start coding.
Come and ask us questions.
Then we've got a later
conversation with Andrew
Kelly, the one man moderator
machine.
So one of the other questions
we got on the Moderator--
by the way, has anyone else got
a question in the Hangout?
No, still quiet.
So the question starts off with
something we can't cover
now, which is will an update of
Google Maps API include a
long press callback for Info
window, something like on info
window, long click listener, or
is there any workaround to
do that now?
I really need that.
So essentially, on the
Maps API, you can
create a little marker.
When you think the marker, it
comes up with an info window
above that.
What McCann is trying to do is
when you long click on the
info window, get a difficult
callback.
So Stephan, you've been kind
of looking into this.
STEPHAN LINZNER: There's no out
of the box solution for
this, so it's not supported.
If you read through the docs,
you will see that the view
that is shown there above the
marker as an info window is
actually not the real
view, it's an image.
So it's not very interactive.
But there was one interesting
post on Stack Overflow.
To be honest, it's a
little bit hacky.
I put it in the Moderator.
So give it a try.
What he basically does is he
wraps his whole layout for the
whole activity, he makes
a custom layout.
And what he does, he's
intercepting touch event there.
He's overwriting on this touch
event and then is looking if
the touch event actually
was on the info window.
And when it was on the info
window, he's going to manually
dispatch the event down
to the info window.
And so the info window is,
again, kind of a live view.
This is what he has successfully
managed to do,
but to me, it sounds kind of
hacky and you should have a
good reason to do it.
We've discussed this before.
A long press on a pop-up in a
Map View, my personal opinion
is you have to have a very
good reason to do it.
But if you have to do it, look
at the Moderator and try to
intercept the touch events
and route them yourself.
This is what you can do.
MATT GAUNT: It's one of these
things, I think it's probably
messed up from the API because
we intend people just to click
on it and then go through to
another screen which will
actually have all the
information and all the
features that you can
do from that point.
So having the long click
listener, I don't know.
I struggle to see a situation
where the experience is going
to really benefit from having
a long click, but I'd be
interested to know what you're
trying to do with it, really.
STEPHAN LINZNER: OK, what
else do we have?
There's a really good
quality of images.
MATT GAUNT: Got another one?
STEPHAN LINZNER: There's one.
I'm just reading through
the comment.
What you can do is, I don't know
where you get your images
from, but what you can do is,
I mean, you obviously will
know the width and the height of
the image in your gallery.
And to make sure the images are
always at a good quality,
just fetch a slightly bigger
image from the server.
And what you also can do is
then scale it down so
that it will fit.
So there are a couple
of strategies.
I think optimizing images for
the gallery is often done on
the server side.
So you request different
representations from the
server for different devices.
But what you never should do
is download very big images
and use them without sampling
them down, because this will
obviously take a
lot of memory.
You can download a big image
if you don't have an image
scanning facility and scale it
down and then put it in a
view, but what you should never
do is take the big image
and put it in a gallery.
And also, recycle your views.
MATT GAUNT: So just to reference
that, that was
referring to a question that we
had on the Google+ stream,
that was essentially, how do you
maintain good quality for
images when writing custom
gallery implementation?
I think just to further what
Stephan was saying, the main
approach that I've seen people
take is essentially, they only
have access to really big
images, and therefore when
you're doing custom gallery,
the best solution that I've
seen is just to scale it down,
store a reference to the full
image as well as the smaller
one, and then just use the
thumbnail within the List
View, and then that way,
you've still got access to the
large one if you need it for
whatever reason.
But you do you have to be
careful with memory management
because you're dealing
with bitmaps.
STEPHAN LINZNER: And Andrew
Kelly just pointed out to
Giusepppe, this is what
I was talking about.
With getting the running task
permission, you can refer to
running a process info
and you can get the
importance from there.
This is where you can tell if
you're in the foreground or
not, but still be very careful
when using it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MATT GAUNT: So this is a
question that maybe Rich or
Nick will have a bit
more insight in.
This is from Phil.
Are unstripped system libraries
available for
download to assist in diagnosing
Android app crashes
below the Dalvik VM?
So essentially, what Phil's
got is he's got a Java
application, there's no NDK,
and somewhere down in the
Dalvik VM, there's
actually a cycle.
And he's kind of posted to a
Google+ link, which then posts
to a Google Group conversation
where someone's actually said
they've got unstripped binaries
which then gives them
access to an extra set
of information.
So I've posted a link to
the Nexus drivers.
Not really sure if that's
related or not,
but it might help.
Do you guys have any insight?
NICK BUTCHER: Nope.
RICH HYNDMAN: I'm looking
through the [INAUDIBLE]
at the moment.
Sometimes you can tell.
Sometimes they've commented
and you can find out
what's going on.
But on this, I can't
see much at all.
MATT GAUNT: I'd be interested
to know what you're doing,
Phil, to kind of cause it.
I think somewhere along the
lines, there was an example of
using a bitmap in one thread,
recycling it in
another, and then it--
RICH HYNDMAN: I'd try the
memory allocation tools.
Run a debug off the app, collect
the memory usage, and
then run it through the MAT, the
Memory Analysis Tool, at
the point when it crashes and
see if you can figure out from
the memory allocations
what's going on.
MATT GAUNT: OK.
STEPHAN LINZNER: So our man Jens
asked another question,
which I think Rich
can comment on.
He's asking for suggestions on
a webcast recording tool from
the device.
They want to record their app
on the device and show the
video to their customers.
I think you're experienced in
recording video from devices.
RICH HYNDMAN: Sure.
If you want to record it into
a PC or a Mac, there's a
number of HDMI recorders.
I've used a Black Magic one.
I was using one a couple
of days ago.
It works very well.
You get the 1080P and 720P
streams that's already through
your Thunderbolt or USB3.
So if you have a look at Black
Magic's website, they have a
few tools there that
work quite well.
The only thing to be careful
of is that your phone or
tablet doesn't have
HTTP keys on it.
So you want to something like
the Motorola Zoom, or the
Galaxy Tab, or the Transformer
Prime, or the Galaxy Nexus.
All these things
will work fine.
But then as soon as you go up to
things like the Nexus 4 and
the Nexus 10 and some of the
newer devices that support
HTTP, most recorders
won't record HTTP
encrypted content, obviously.
So just be careful with that,
but I'm using the one from
Black Magic and it works
absolutely perfectly for me.
NICK BUTCHER: A viable attempt,
if you can, is that
you use an emulator or a
desktop software like
BlueStacks or something like
that and use some desktop
recording software as well.
You get quite good
frame rates then.
STEPHAN LINZNER: OK.
We have an interesting question,
I think, from
Stephan from Berlin.
He's asking what's the best
approach to migrate a phone
app, no fragments,
to a tablet app.
This is an interesting
question.
What's the best approach?
I think the best approach is
to go over the sequential
screens on the phone and ask
yourself how will you lay out
these screens on a tablet?
And after you've done that, you
should probably continue
on taking each activity and
refactoring out every code
that has to go from the activity
to the fragment, and
put all screens in fragments.
And then after that, you're
going to start rearranging it
on the tablet.
But that's what I would do, is
I would think about which
activities which visible views
to the user go where on a
tablet, and then I would
refactor out the fragments,
and then I would do all the
rearranging for the phone and
the tablet.
So you can do it step by step.
What can be very helpful when
doing it is to use something
like an event bus because
it allows you to
decouple things like that.
So you can still use the old
code while also running a
fragment because the events tend
to make code more loosely
coupled, so this is an approach
I've taken on which
worked very well because you can
still keep the app running
and having some fragments
there.
But generally, take on the
phone code, extract some
fragments, and then rearrange
it for the tablet version.
MATT GAUNT: I think that
sounds about right.
I think you just need to
genuinely think about how you
want to chunk up the logic of
the application into fragments
because obviously, you're
going to want
to move them around.
And once you've figured that
out, start moving those bits
of logic you already have
into in the fragment.
And like Stephan said, then
you're good to go.
STEPHAN LINZNER: There's
a short question.
I'm a newbie.
Why don't pages like
developer.android.com?
I have no links to examples.
Where can you get
the sample apps?
You can get it from, if
you use a [INAUDIBLE]
Android tool--
NICK BUTCHER: Sorry, actually,
the important thing you missed
out when you read that link is
he was talking about the
design site
developer.android.com/design,
specifically on linked code
stuff, so they're specifically
resources targeted mostly at
designers, and they're not
supposed to be backed up by
implementation steps.
STEPHAN LINZNER: You're right.
MATT GAUNT: So I think generally
with this kind of
stuff, when you start looking,
so if you're finding something
in the Action Bar that's
mentioned in the design
guidelines.
When you actually then start
looking at the documentation
for the Action Bar, you'll
actually start finding guides
that'll explain how to do each
particular part that will be
kind of referenced in the
design guidelines.
So I think they are decoupled
for a good reason, but
generally, the documentation is
still there to back it up
and help you in whatever
way you need to.
So I think it's quite a
good way of doing it.
And like Nick said, it's one of
those things, anything that
gets designers to start thinking
in an Android when
they're not really used
to it is good.
And scaring them off with code
and certain things like that,
if they're not into that, then
it's best to leave it.
NICK BUTCHER: I think
it's good and bad.
I want all developers to read
the Design Guide, and I could
see the benefit for
having links
through to some examples.
So I can see the argument.
I get it completely where
you're coming from.
But at the same time, like
Matt says, we want to be
accessible to non-developers
as well, to designers and
people who might get scared off
by links through to all
that stuff.
So there's arguments for both
sides, and this is the way
we've fallen on this
argument right now.
MATT GAUNT: Andrew Kelly's
asked a question.
In the absence of--
I'm going to answer this
one last question.
In the absence of being able
to use the Google Maps
Fragment inside an app widget,
would you see any problems
using an image from static
Google Maps API instead?
I like to link to periodically
call location updates show
places of interest nearby.
So Stephan's linked to Android
Design in Action next week,
which I believe you guys are
covering widgets, Nick?
NICK BUTCHER: That
was yesterday.
That went out yesterday.
MATT GAUNT: There you go.
We've already done it.
So what would you say to this?
I personally don't think it's
that bad of an idea.
I think dealing with the
densities, it might be a bit
of an issue, but I'm sure
Andrew can deal with it.
NICK BUTCHER: It
sounds doable.
I think I would just be careful
about how frequently
you're going to do something
like that.
RICH HYNDMAN: And of course, if
you're using static images
from Google Maps, make sure you
abide by all the relevant
terms and conditions put the
copyrights and licenses at the
bottom of the pictures.
We have a static image
generator.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, no cropping
out the cropping.
RICH HYNDMAN: Exactly, no
cropping out the logo.
STEPHAN LINZNER: Yeah,
but just give it a
try and let us know.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, it would
be cool to find out
what you're up to.
So unfortunately, that
is our half hour.
We have steamed through so many
questions, it is untrue.
But thank you for
joining us and
chatting with your questions.
If you've got any more, then
stick them in the Moderator
for next week where we'll be
doing another office hours.
NICK BUTCHER: Guiseppe asked
where in the comments which
I'm not touching with
a barge pole.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah,
neither am I.
NICK BUTCHER: How long will
it take for Google Air
tickets to sell out?
MATT GAUNT: You tell us.
It depends.
Anyway, thank you, everyone.
STEPHAN LINZNER: All
right, guys.
See you next week.
NICK BUTCHER: Bye, guys.
RICH HYNDMAN: Bye bye.
AUDIENCE: Bye, guys.